14 años después del intento fallido de
pacificar las favelas de río de janeiro
el gobierno local lanza una nueva
operación llamada ciudad integrada con
el objetivo de reducir la violencia en
esos barrios de la ciudad
la operación arrancaba esta madrugada
con un dispositivo de 1200 agentes que
han entrado en la favela de jacarezinho
donde en mayo del año pasado se
registraba la mayor masacre policial de
la extendería con un saldo de 28
residentes muertos esta mañana no ha
habido enfrentamientos armados porque
según nos han contado habitantes de esta
favela los narcotraficantes que
controlan este territorio ya sabían de
esta operación prefirieron salir de
noche para evitar enfrentamientos
armados además la policía también ha
entrado en otras favelas de la zona
oeste de río de janeiro llamada moussem
a donde la presencia de los grupos
paramilitares conocidos como milicias es
muy fuerte el objetivo del gobierno es
ahora ocupar unas favelas estratégicas
patrullar
el territorio a esos grupos de narcos
sin embargo muchos habitantes con los
que hemos hablado hoy temen que sea otra
operación de maquillaje político antes
de las elecciones de este año y temen
que no se resuelva nada como aconteció
con las unidades de la policía
pacificadora que fueron desmanteladas
después de los juegos olímpicos eso sí
ellos temen que de nuevo haya un
abordaje agresivo con los habitantes de
las favelas y que se criminalice una
población que en su mayoría es
constituida por trabajadores